they're ideal is Sport inclusive for all
but how to balance that with fairness
and sporting Integrity for what
Athletics it means no transgender women
being allowed in female events the
decision was taken in consultation with
a number of stakeholders including 40
member federations
our coaches our athletes and through the
athletes commission as well as a range
of other community groups including
trans groups un experts the
international Olympic Committee and para
Athletics there are athletes now who
will feel excluded and discriminated
against what is your message to them as
they feel
this pain perhaps that the decision that
the Council made is a primarily
principled based decision and that is
the overarching need to protect the
female category this is what our sport
is here to do and I think the council
has done that today this ruling only
covers world ranking events and World
Athletics says there are no transgender
female athletes currently in
international competitions who've been
through male puberty but the impact of
the decision resonates Beyond sport
as a population group trans women are
not a threat to women's sport trans
women are still hugely underrepresented
across all levels of women's sport it is
true that trans women maintain some
physical advantages over CIS women but
these advantages have not led to
overrepresentation
World Athletics had initially preferred
basing entry to the female category on
blood testosterone levels for Trans
athletes but ultimately there was no
widespread support for that also
rejected was having a new open category
that did find backing at this track
where hopefuls dream of competing at the
2024 Paris Olympics as we know the men's
times are so much faster than female
times so I think
um already you kind of know that they
would have some sort of physiological
advantage over the CMO athletes and so I
do think it would be better to have an
open category and become inclusive as to
have no category at all this is a
landmark ruling for sports a tougher
decision than anticipated ultimately
World Athletics has followed swimming
and rugby in deciding only those female
at Birth can compete in women's events
other sports including football are
still reviewing their transgender
eligibility policies
World Athletics will continue to consult
transgender athletes and could review
its decision but for now ensuring an
unfair sporting Advantage is not gained
has been prioritized over inclusion